case stamina you've come to stoke today
a place where labour lost two seats in
the last german election you've been
spending some time talking to students
have they given you a better idea about
how you win back stoke in the next
election
yes and it's really good to be able to
talk to them um the first thing is they
think it's very important that i'm in
stoke they want the discussion about
stoke to be here
not in london and elsewhere and that's
why this is the latest in a series of um
visits i've done all summer i've been in
different places across the country all
summer usually for two or three days at
a time
um actually investing time having
putting some ideas on the table and
talking about them but in particular
talking to people who don't vote labor
one thing i was really struck
with today because i've talked to young
people these are 16 17 a couple of 18
year olds
and i was saying what's you know the
biggest issue for you in stoke and they
said it's it's safety and security on
the streets and they're worried about
anti-social behavior
about drugs and the fact that they don't
see enough police officers and they
openly reference that the police station
had been shut down now quite often i
think we think that that sort of law and
order issue
um safety issue is something which
perhaps is
more acute with the older generation but
actually for young people here a couple
of young women were saying to me i don't
go into the high street i certainly
wouldn't go into the high street sort of
after hours
really really struck me as something
that profoundly needs change okay well
in that classroom after you left i hope
you don't mind but i asked them what
they thought of you i thought you would
yeah
do my job and the consensus in the room
was that they liked you they thought you
were nice but they didn't think you were
a leader
well uh they're wrong about that um my
job is to lead my party which i've also
been doing changing the party
but also to lead the country and and
you know leaders come in different
shapes and sizes and the most important
thing about a leader is what is that
leader going to do what is that leader
going to change and we had and in the
end we were with those students for the
best part of an hour and a half after
you spoke to them and we talked about
the jobs that they want to see in stoke
i was really struck that
when i asked them how many of you think
you're going to have to leave stoke to
get the job that you want um many of
them put their hand up pretty well all
of them put their hand up so they were
very interested in that question of one
of the jobs of the
future as i've said you know what is the
position in relation to policing and
crime
very acutely aware of the
climate crisis and we were having a
really strong discussion about that and
what they wanted to hear from me what i
was saying to them is we're going to do
this in relation to jobs we are going to
end insecure jobs low paid jobs invest
in the future with a you know 10-year
strategy
develop on you know health and social
care and mental health they were
particularly concerned about um and on
education and the sense they want a
broader approach to life but in your
summer of loan and we'll come on to that
has that sometimes been the feedback
that you've you've got that people like
you you're personable but they don't
really
see what you stand for they don't see
you as a leader do you think there's
something there is there a knob in there
where you have to do better well let me
tell you we've been doing this for now i
don't know how many weeks
in different parts of the country
lots of conversations you know in the
workplace
in factories in schools in colleges
in community centers in a bingo hall
i've been just about everywhere three
big things come out of that and they're
not actually what you said the three big
things are
that boris johnson's wearing a bit thin
people
realize um
that he's all slogan and no substance
that's the first thing the second thing
is they really want change when i asked
them and we talked about what the future
looks like including today with the
students here they want change they
desperately frustratingly want change
they can see a better future out there
and they want us to get to that better
future when we talked about me and the
labour party um what i was struck by was
they were open
to voting labor and i was remember i've
been trying to talk to people who don't
vote labor many labor leaders go around
the country wanting to talk to people
who already support the labour party i
asked to be talking all summer to people
who don't vote labour
and
they said to me we're open to it we one
woman said to me i want to vote labour
again but you now have to persuade me
you have to show me what the labour
party is going to do now given that we
lost as badly as we did
back in 2019 to
to to have the position now where people
say well i'm open to it i'm not close to
the idea that is a really important step
in the right direction obviously
what that means for me and the labour
party is that
we need to use this autumn now as we
come out of the pandemic to set out what
that future look looks like um so we can
earn their vote in the next general
election okay well let's move on let's
move on to policy after your summer of
listening i mean this week a huge policy
a potentially election defining policy
from the prime minister
he broke a manifesto promise he has a
huge tax hike he still got it through
the commons with just five rebels i mean
he's run rings around you this week
hasn't he well what he's done this week
is
introduce a massive tax hike for working
people
without meeting the key tests of
what genuinely changing
social care and health
would mean so i think the three most
important questions are
in relation to the prime minister's own
approach
will his plan
mean that people who need
care and particularly going into care
homes
don't have to sell their houses their
homes
and the answer that is yes they still
will have to sell their homes if you're
in stoke or anywhere else around the
country and you've got a house um you
know towards your retirement that's
worth about 150 000 pounds and perhaps
some savings then you're going to be
paying 100 you're going to be paying 86
000 pounds towards your care and i the
question i put to the prime minister
yesterday was um let's say someone's got
a house of about 150 000 and bitter
savings and then they get a bill for 86
000 pounds how do they pay that without
selling their house didn't have an
answer because there isn't an answer
they would have to sell it second the
second test is
is this a plan that will genuinely bring
down waiting lists by the time of the
next general election again the answer
from the prime minister is no it's not
going to achieve that
so it doesn't of the two things that he
set out to achieve it's not going to
achieve it the third test is is it fair
because this is an approach that puts
all the heavy lifting on working people
and the example i put to the prime
minister yesterday was a woman called
rosie she's a care worker single mum
with children she works in a care home
and she's now getting a double whammy
which is increased national insurance
tax burden and she's going to suffer the
withdrawal of universal credit the
uplift so she's going to have to pay you
know a thousand pounds or more she's
going to lose a thousand pounds or more
a year she's she wanted more shifts
she's looked around for child care and
she can't get it she's at her wit's end
and the question for the prime minister
is why on earth are you hammering
working people yeah but he
has put through manifesto breaking
uh tax policy
he is promising to save the nhs he's
saying that he is the party of the
united states he's voted it's through
he's you've got to get he's put you in a
tricky position he's a canny politician
isn't he well he's
he has introduced a an unfair
tax hike for working people
which isn't going to fix social care
um and isn't going to bring down waiting
lists
and let's just advance also
you can argue that and in three years
time you could be proven right but in
the run-up to that he has parked his
tanks on labour's lawn he is the party
of the nhs and you the labour party
voted against a tax hike
that gives 36 billion pounds to the nhs
and that will be on every conservative
leaflet at the next election labour
doesn't back the nhs uh
could you look uh this is a government
that before we went into pandemic
had underfunded the nhs waiting lists
were spiraling before the pandemic how
could you be the party of nhs if waiting
lists are supposed to just put through a
tax rise to raise 36.
vacancies um across the nhs were a cause
of chronic problems this is a government
that's run down
the nhs and that's why i described it as
a sticking power plaster over a gaping
wound that they have created but look
the central question you put to me is
you know he's put this money on the
table the problem for the prime minister
now
is
delivery
is he going to be able to go to the next
election and say
nobody
needs to sell their house
in their home for care no he's not he
doesn't even say that now let alone at
the election is he going to go to the
election and say i've brought down
waiting lists i've cleared the waiting
list backlog no because he doesn't even
say now he can do that
is he going to go to the election and be
able to say i've actually solved the
problems of social care because we've
talked a lot this week about funding
but the change we need to see in social
care is much deeper than that um a third
of those um in social care are adults
with disabilities
there are millions of acts of social
care that aren't being done
at home
and you know most people want their care
at home and then he must have surprised
did it surprise you a bit though this
policy it must have caught you on the
hop a bit no just hear me out um the the
one of the major problems with um social
care is that we've got an underfunded
undervalued workforce there's a reason
that there's a high turnover in care
workers um and that there are huge
numbers of vacancies and that's because
it's underpaid and undervalued and
that's why
what i think
we need to do
is to have a preventative approach to
social care way before people have to go
into care homes to make sure that the
acts of support that are needed in the
home which often if they're not done
lead later deterioration are done we
have a principle that says
you should be able to stay at home just
hear me out on this stay at home and
that we then put in support for the
the workforce
professionalize it bring up the
rates of pay and the value that we put
in those that are working in the sector
because if we don't fix those bits
then um
the argument about um you know
whether you have to sell your home just
be it is a small part an important part
but a small part of the overall picture
but how can you credibly claim to be the
party of nhs when you just voted against
a 36 billion pound
tax rise to fund the nhs you can go into
whether what the tories did in the past
under fun whatever you want to argue
from this week that is the message boris
johnson is willing to take difficult
decisions on taxation in order to have a
better plan
well he had i mean he broke a manifesto
promise well he's broken manifestly
broken manifesto promises left right and
center um
that is a different matter but what he
had
if the prime minister put forward a plan
that would genuinely fix social care
and that was would genuinely bring down
waiting lists by the next election
and that was underpinned by
fair funding and fair taxation i would
support it what i won't support
is a plan which doesn't fix social care
doesn't scratch the surface of social
care he isn't going to bring down the
waiting list
i'm listening
on working people
so you're quite relaxed when he says
he's the party of the nhs it does have
the nhs for 10 years they've starved the
nhs and you know
only a few months ago they were
proposing a one percent pay rise to the
nhs which was a pay cut i tell you what
my wife works in the nhs
and i've been in many many hospitals um
over the years and particularly in the
last few months and the idea that
anybody working in the nhs thinks that
the tory party party nhs it is
ridiculous but in three years when the
nhs has been given an additional 25
billion in funding because he did a tax
rise it might feel more like the
conservative party's part of the nhs and
you've got a big problem
in the i mean the nhs frontline have
done an amazing job in the last 18
months dealing with covert they're now
facing up to the crisis of um waiting
lists and what they want is to be able
to be clear that that waiting list will
be
reduced the backlog will be reduced by
the next general election the prime
minister is not saying or doing that
but the other big issue here is
in terms of how you fund this
um there's a huge divide between me and
the prime minister the prime minister
wants a tax hike for working people he's
putting all of the weight on working
people i say it should be on those that
have the broader shoulders and the
example i put to the prime minister
yesterday was this
a landlord with several properties
um doesn't pay a penny more
his or her tenants in work
um pay more tax in national insurance
and and
for working people particularly those
who are going to have a cut in universal
credit this is a huge double whack okay
let's see all the ways to raise this
money
why hammer well let's okay let's i was
going to come to it but you've brought
me to it so let's let's dig into this
your response
about this has actually irritated quite
a lot of people in your party in the
public as well i think because
you criticize the policy you say what's
wrong that you very skillfully explore
that exploit that at the dispatch box
but you don't actually give voters an
alternative in fact one of the kids said
to me i know what kierstama
stands against what does he stand for
what's the policy what does he believe
so what does the broader shoulders pay
that what does that mean well what i'd
do with social care is to
introduce a preventative principle to
make sure that we intervene much earlier
on
with those million acts of support that
are needed before people even need
care homes
i would introduce um an at-home
approach at home first which would allow
people to stay at home rather than going
into care homes by putting the support
in for them and supporting them that are
caring for them and i put in a package
for those working in the care sector so
they're properly valued and properly
paid on secure contracts so they are the
practical measures which will actually
make a difference to social care when it
comes to funding it
i wouldn't uh look to working people
and have a tax hike on them
i would say that those with the broader
shoulders
should pay well that means that
those that earn their money or their
income from uh
things other than work
should pay their fair share
well um there is we you know there's a
whole range of uh
people who earn their money from
property
dividends stocks shares
um
you know capital gains tax these should
all be looked at as a broader fairer way
of raising taxes so in principle you
would prefer a wealth tax of some sort i
think we should look at all of these
options and we shouldn't say that the
whole weight has to fall on working
people that the people who earn their
living from a wage why shouldn't those
that get their money from other means
whether it's dividends stocks shares
property pay their fair share and the
landlord example is a very important one
why should a landlord not pay a penny
but the working tenant because they're
running away
taxes than a raise of income tax i think
we should look across the board at
something that is fair but at the moment
you would offer
a wealth tax to raise an income tax i
think we look at a broad range here um
but the idea that we don't the one thing
the prime minister is that just do you
prefer in principle wealth taxes to
income tax increases i think we need to
look at a range of options you're not
going to answer well we need to look at
a range of options but that includes
the way people earn their money whether
it's from earned wages or whether it's
from rent or stocks and dividends and
i think we should look at all that
because in the end it should be
the principle that um those with the
broadest shoulders pay their fair share
okay so just to summarize
national insurance you think you'll
answer that because you think it's
unfair on working people
income tax could be looked at
uh but it seems to me that you think
that when you say those with the broader
shoulders you are looking at those with
wealth taxes you are looking at those
we're looking at the precisely the um
sorts of income that rachel reeves
identified yesterday which is income
from property income for dividends
stocks shares etcetera the so
the income that comes not from your
wages because what the government is
doing is putting this all on
on working people so that's not that it
isn't taxes
taxes look i'm trying you down because i
actually want you to say yes or no i
think we should look at a wealth tax it
doesn't commit you to the policy it just
says to me that that's your preferred
option and that's very clear and it's
very clear to the public yes all of
those options are a wealth tax i mean
you know in the broadest sense of the
world and we should look at it okay andy
burnham
uh
of course he came up with the policy a
decade ago he said an interview with sky
yesterday that he'd like you to outline
your planet conference is that what you
intend to do
well i've already set out what i think
is wrong with social care and
what i think we need to do about it
although
first and foremost those three things
preventative model
um an at-home first principle um and
making sure that the workforce is secure
properly rewarded et cetera so we
actually set that out back in april of
this year and are you going to say more
of a conference or do you feel like if
you establish the principles you have
time to then decide the policy well i
think
the most important thing about a plan is
have you identified what the problems
are
and we have have you identified the
principles for fixing them and we have
have you identified the principle for
funding and we have obviously this needs
to develop now we need to look at
whatever the government brings forward
when it brings forward a white paper but
in terms of the principles that should
be applied i think we've very clearly um
identified those preventative principle
um the at her
care at home principle
and making sure the workforce is
properly rewarded properly recognized
okay and just finally labour party
conference last year you had to give
your inaugural speech as leader
down the camera barrel which must have
been difficult not in the room uh
feeding off the audience that's not a
easy thing to do
this year
what's the
tenor of the speech you've had a
difficult six months you lost harley
pool you lost your depar deposit in
amisham and cheshire you barely can't
clung on in battle in spain do you see
this conference speech as a sort of
relaunch of your leadership is it make
or break for you it's not a relaunch uh
by any shape all means we've we've been
through i mean last year i had to give
my conference speech to say down the
barrel of a of a camera really difficult
but we've been through 18 months for
pandemic and in a pandemic i think that
most people are predominantly concerned
about their own health not getting the
virus
whether they've got their job or not
this is the first opportunity that i've
really got to to give the future look
what what does britain look like post
pandemic what are we going to say about
the future of work what are we going to
say about the future of education and
skills what are we going to say about
you know the 10-year plan that we need
for the health service that goes way
beyond
waiting lists and deals with the the
underlying question of people living for
longer and how we use technology to deal
with that
and also how do we
meet our targets in relation to the
climate crisis and how do we see that as
an opportunity so this is a chance i
think for
um me to set out what the future looks
uh like
and
again one of the things i've taken away
from
all the various discussions i've had
over the course of this summer is people
desperately want change and they want to
know there's a better future out there
and we're going to set out what that
looks like and just one more thing
you've been doing this for five years or
six years as a politician 18 months as
leader
you're more experienced as a lawyer
really than a politician i think that's
fair you've done you did law for long
you're in a politician what do you think
you can learn from boris johnson as a
political leader
not very much
um i i
believe
uh whether it's laurel politics
that um integrity
and honesty
matter
i mean he and i are very different
in relation to that and um you know
leaders come in different shapes and
different sizes but i think uh that it's
very important that people see who yes i
came to politics late um yes i did other
things i ran a public service i know
what it means to actually make change on
a national scale i know what it means to
be held accountable i know what it means
to work with other people to bring about
real change
and i bring that to politics and so
i'm not
much interested in shouting and
screaming about a problem i want to know
what is the problem how are we going to
fix it
and that's the sort of politician i am
he has approval ratings of -23 and yours
and -39 so
whatever he does the public seems to
like it more than they like you those
pollings go like this over the months
and over the years as you know one time
boris johnson's here then he's here i'm
there i'm there the only one the only
poll that matters is the poll of the
next general election and that is what
we are working to that is what we're
utterly focused on and everything i'm
doing
is guided by the question does this
improve our chance of winning the next
general election and i'm determined that
we will thank you very much thank you